nous avons rencontré des Ukrainiens qui
sont certes soulagés d'être libérés de
la présence russe mais qui pour autant
reste très traumatisé par ces huit mois
d'occupation la parole se libère
notamment sur ces cas de torture que
vous mentionnez alors que les crimes les
enquêtes pour crime de guerre continue
dans la région les villageois qu'on en a
rencontrés ils nous ont parlé de la
crainte de la peur du climat de peur
dans lequel ils ont vécu ces dernières
ces derniers mois alors qu'ils voyaient
leurs voisins se faire arrêter de façon
complètement arbitraire on nous a
raconté qu'il suffisait parfois d'avoir
ne serait-ce qu'une photo arborant le
drapeau ukrainien ou bien des poèmes
patriotiques dans son téléphone pour se
faire arrêter et ensuite être envoyé
dans des prisons ou bien dans des
immeubles que les troupes russes occupés
et qui étaient réhabilités dans des
centres de
pardon dans des centres de provisoire de
détention dans lesquelles les forces
russes auraient commis des actes de
torture les quatre sites qui ont été
découverts aujourd'hui à Carson et bien
et bien il s'agissait effectivement
d'immeubles de civils et les personnes
et rescapées qui ont pu commencer à
témoigner sur ce qu'ils ont vécu ils
parlent de nombreux cas d'électrochoc au
niveau de leur tête de leur partie
génitales de leurs doigts ou bien encore
qui se faisait battre à coup de barres
en métal ou de battre de baseball pour
le moment Moscou n'a pas vraiment
répondu à ces accusations
d'atrocités commises mais d'un autre
côté elle accuse les autorités russes
accusent les soldats Ukrainiens d'avoir
commis des crimes de guerre et de son
côté les autorités ukrainiennes elles
ont mobilisé une équipe d'experts afin
d'analyser les preuves vidéos envoyées
par les forces russes mais en tout cas
au-delà de ces cas de torture la
population est continue de vivre dans la
terreur elle est toujours ciblée dans sa
vie quotidienne aujourd'hui à Carson une
boulangerie a été la cible de frappe et
quatre personnes au moins auraient été
bless